happy holidays everybody i'm ash carlson
now let's talk about one of the most
recognizable holiday movies ever made
that's also celebrating its 30th
anniversary
yes i'm talking about home alone
entertainment tonight was on set of the
instant holiday hit in 1990
here's a look back at the making of the
flick that got us saying keep the change
a filthy animal
i made my family disappear yeah
welcome to home alone ma'am i'm eight
years old
you think i'd be here alone i don't
think so
is this making sense so far yes
it's odd looking back on it it's a
different life it's a different lifetime
ago mom dad
where are you guys it's about um
a little boy who accidentally gets left
home
alone around christmas time kevin dan
stern and i play
burglars and this house i really like i
really want to rob this house
and the kid turns out to be one of these
genius kids you know
and he does a number on these two
burglars that's hysterical i mean he
just
he wipes this out as you can see this is
my house
i have to defend it
there we go stand by settle it's the
dream when you make a christmas movie
for it to become one of those movies
that people watch
every christmas so be nice
we hope everyone in this family hates me
[Laughter]
we didn't know if we were funny i mean
we didn't know if we could be funny
and there's a lot of action running from
one room another
it's a perfect little movie in a way
because it's a
it's a kid thwarting the big guys
[Music]
stepping on the
christmas ornaments paint cans
[Music]
i mean it was just balls out
silly don't worry marv i'll get them for
you
i do remember that tarantula on on my
face which
i got to the set and i'm like is there
like a
rubber tarantula they had the they had
the tarantula in a box and i'm like
that's that's good and what else are we
gonna you know use
and so we got to the day of shooting and
they said yeah that didn't work
out didn't look real that's when i let
out a scream that i think i copied from
psycho
[Applause]
action i was really you know terrified
throughout the first
couple of days of shooting and mcauley
had not done a lot at that point so
i wanted to make sure that his
performance was was really strong
he's the leading man of the movie this
is it don't get scared now
i was just walking to my friend's house
and this guy
he starts walking up he goes hey
they say i saw your movie i liked it yes
yes yes yes
we hadn't owned this house for very long
and i had just finished
renovating it
it was amazing how well the house fit
the script
and the needs of the script people
started driving by
those two days christmas eve and
christmas day we had over 400 cars
each day and they're still driving by
and getting out and taking photographs
you can hear people laughing sometimes
and i think it's as their eye travels up
to the third floor window and sees
kevin's face peering back at them
they're going to drive by anyway we
might as well
give them a smile when they get here you
better get out of here before somebody
sees us
lunch one hour me and chris decided that
we
would use a dollar shot yeah what should
i do here okay
do a dollar shot you think so yeah this
is me in a two shot
now you guys it's just me and dan i
don't know why you're standing you don't
have to this is just a two shot
of me and dan he knows all the lingo you
know he's
he's great sometimes chris needs some
help setting up shots holy culkin shows
going all around the world and action
but either they just run around it just
just basically be a nine-year-old given
a camcorder which is a big deal
this is behind
i guess what people consider an iconic
moment which is on the poster where he's
doing that
um the script called for him to put
you know shaving lotion on and suddenly
it burns his skin and he screams
when he first did it i never expected
his hands to stay
attached to his cheeks and the scream to
happen like that
and when we saw that we we had to stop
ourselves from laughing
and we didn't know it was gonna it was
gonna be the universal image for home
alone
hello i hope it's funny i hope
everybody's laughing while i'm sitting
there
i hope they like it a lot you guys give
up or you're thirsty for more
it's still funny in the way now today
that it was back then
and i think it will continue to be i
think it's a classic movie and it's just
i'm very very proud to be a part of that
that's it we're done
keep the change you filthy animals